[Music]
it's monday the 28th of june lifting
lockdown
early easing of restrictions expected to
be ruled out as the new health secretary
preps for his first
big day in the new job something we may
have seen coming
would you answer the call if your prime
minister wanted you in cabinet again
no i'm not going to speculate about that
oh that's a yes then isn't it
country of concern as germany looks to
ban all british holidaymakers from the
eu
portugal imposes a two-week quarantine
for uk tourists who haven't had two jobs
military top brass in isolation
including six top commanders and the
defense secretary with their sinkhole
under that first building so i just want
to know
we're the fire department we're first
responders we have no idea
searching for answers families question
authorities as the search for survivors
at a collapsed miami apartment block
continues
and kovid alert at wimbledon forces
british number one johanna conte
to withdraw from the competition we're
live at the club as the grand slam
gets underway
[Music]
heavy rain and thunderstorms for
southern parts of the country today
sunshine in the north all the weather
details coming up later
[Music]
good morning everybody he's only been in
the job a little over 24 hours but the
new health secretary
has his first big test today when he
updates mps in the commons
on plans to ease kovid restrictions he
said he is keen to get back to normal as
soon as possible
but the prime minister is expected to
rule out unlocking further
before the 19th of july at the earliest
questions too this morning about the man
who came before him and who leaked the
footage of matt hancock
our deputy political editor sam coats
reports
first day proper for the new health
secretary and thrown straight into the
two-week unlocking review over whether
to get rid of remaining restrictions
we are still in a pandemic and i want to
see that come to an
end as soon as possible and that will be
my most
immediate priority on the ground in the
new health secretary's constituency of
bronze grove south west of birmingham
people here want him to move forward
with the right balance when it comes to
unlocking decisions and future
restrictions
could his economic background as a
former chancellor make a difference
he might be less cautious but we think
more about the economy but uh um
you gotta hope he's uh he's got an eye
on the uh
the good nature of the uh the country
really i hope that he's more straight
with us
and because people are very confused
because even i'm confused and i work
with the energies
i don't want any more uh lockdowns to
happen let's see anything i'm
i'm worried about um so yeah but i think
they do a really good job
sydney conservatives on his own back
benches feel the same
i hope now this time saturday with a
fresh mind on this we'll come to this
and
look at the evidence if we really are
following the evidence
the truth is yes there's an infection
rate but the truth is it's
hospitalization
deaths which are critical and i think
the evidence is pointing clearly
to the fact that we've broken the link
with hospitalization and death
sadget javid set expectations sky-high
amongst mps and the public
yesterday when he said that his
immediate priority was to get life
back to normal as soon as possible and
as health secretary he'll have power
over
face coverings restrictions foreign
holidays but with case numbers up
60 week on week would he really end up
being that different to his predecessor
the opposition still want to talk about
this his predecessor
the infamous picture from friday's son
appears to have come
from cctv in his own office
but is it fair game for ministers to be
filmed
there is an issue as to how that got
leaked because that is a security issue
in its own
right but i think i think the public
would
know and expect most people would see
that cctv
is there and it's there for a reason a
fixture of our lives for the last 16
months
about to disappear from view could it
nudge britain
onto a faster path out of restrictions
sam coates sky news
delighted to say the justice secretary
robert buckland is with us now it's
always a pleasure mr buckland thank you
for joining us
this morning why do you think that saudi
japanese will make a good health
secretary
well i think sajid brings a wealth of
experience from
other government departments he's uh
shall we say a bit of a political
veteran
uh and i think that uh he brings a fresh
perspective
as well to these uh vitally important
issues
um i have every confidence that he will
start to work and get to grips with
these important issues
he's going to look at some major matters
today
with the government and i look forward
to hearing his statement to the commons
with matt hancock why did boris johnson
say the matter was
closed i mean how out of touch with the
mood of the nation was that
well look i think there was a swirl of
things going on uh
here there were of course the private
matters the private life matters
and indeed as the hours went by uh it
was uh
clear that there was uh i think an
understandable groundswell
of concern about uh how important it is
that
those who set the rules keep to them
and uh i think that when we look back at
this we will see
that uh uh it took it took a a you know
a day or so but the right outcome was
achieved and it was correct for uh matt
hancock to resign
why did the prime minister react before
he knew all the facts then
well look i i i i i don't precisely know
what what was said between them but what
i do know
is that matt hancock had worked
tirelessly
for the past 18 months or so he'd be
longer as health secretary
it's always difficult to lose somebody
with such experience
that's basic we have been through this
long road on this long road
there is a absolute logic in trying to
make sure that we
have continuity that the person who was
involved in this from the beginning uh
stayed to the end of it but um uh i
i think the circumstances became
overwhelmingly clear
that uh credibility was at stake
and that is why mr hancock resigned just
because he's resigned doesn't mean
we shouldn't have answers labour has
called for the release of all documents
related to uh gina color angelo's
employment
at the department of health would you
back that
well i think that if there are any
issues uh to be
explored then the cabinet office which
is ultimately responsible for all
appointments uh would be able to assist
uh i think there are a range of issues
here that are
being raised uh everything that i
understand so far
uh leads me to believe that due process
was followed in the appointment of this
person
uh and that any declarations that should
have been made were made
but ultimately it's a matter of the
cabinet office uh who
oversee public appointments so you agree
that there should be an investigation
well as i said uh what i have
the information that suggests that due
process
was followed and i've no reason to uh
doubt or dispute that
uh public appointments uh have to be
evidenced very carefully
uh it's not just uh you know somebody
picking up picking up the phone on a
whim
it has to be done properly and i would
expect that in this case like in every
other case
due process was followed so what
information do you have about when they
started their relationship given that
she was employed by the department of
health last september
um we have to believe that they weren't
in a relationship
then otherwise it would be against the
rules
um some of the morning's papers are
suggesting
that there were rumors about their
relationship some two years ago you're
confident
that their relationship only started in
may well okay
i don't know i mean well you said that
you did know so that's why i'm asking
you mr buckley you said you don't think
that any rules have been broken so i'm
asking you to underline why you think
that is
what i said was that i'm confident the
due process was followed and that
declarations were made as to
when the relationship began i'm afraid i
i don't know
uh but um you know these these processes
aren't
as i say the whim of one person they
have to be checked and double checked
by others who know the rules
and uh due through that process
declarations
should be made about any personal
connection uh that should that
is clearly understood by everybody
involved or should be
but okay as to when their relationship
started i'm afraid i don't have that
information
but you acknowledge that that's all
important well look
i think it's really important in public
life that if there are connections that
should be declared
um that's common in not just in public
life but in
in all walks of life and i would expect
that this would be
uh no exception and what if there
haven't been
well i don't know okay i mean uh mr
buckland you can't just say i don't know
i mean the point is
if they were in a relationship and we
were paying 15 grand a year
for him to have his mistress at the
office that's not acceptable
no if declarations weren't made then
clearly that is highly irregular
inappropriate
but what i was saying was that you know
trying to answer your questions about
the fact
i i don't know precisely when the
relationship began but what i would
expect
is that declarations uh should be made
if indeed there was that degree of
connection at the time i understood
uh using a private email address to
conduct government business
uh basically doing it in secret that's
against the rules isn't it
yeah i mean we should use government
emails
uh i think that's very clear i think
that
even if other emails were used perhaps
in an emergency or in a rush
then uh there should be a way of
collating that information should it be
needed in
future i think it's much simpler to just
use the government system
um and then everybody knows where the
data is
uh stored uh but as i said you know
uh sometimes in an emergency uh perhaps
a you know
another email address has to be used if
a device isn't
to hand but the key there is retention
and making sure that that information is
available
for anybody else to look at if there was
uh further scrutiny
so what's your view on that that's not
what the former health secretary did
again i think the cabinet office if
they're asked to
probably will be willing to satisfy
themselves that
if that was the case then the material
is
available uh i think it's really
important not just from a historical
point of view but from a public
accountability point of view
that uh all data uh uh appropriately uh
disposable is available
and that's why i think it's wise to use
government systems so that
that material is much more easily
retrievable and foolhardy not to
well i look i i we we went through some
pretty extraordinary times okay
i mean there were there were emergency
situations that had to be dealt with
very readily and very quickly uh
and sometimes uh you know if your device
isn't a hand then a message has to be
conveyed
speedily i think the important thing is
that if that is done then
uh attention must be drawn to the need
to make sure that that information is is
in a retrievable
form um would you do it sir
i use uh government email uh i use
government systems
uh i always use the process uh i think
it's important that
we do that uh it just makes my life
easier
easier and it makes those the lives of
those around me much easier
[Music]
have you ever used a private email for
government business no i haven't
no understood understood um how should
the cctv breach be investigated in in
your opinion
we heard uh yesterday from jeremy hunt
he said that potentially it's a
a breach of uh the uh what was the
phrase that he
used uh official secrets act
well i think that um there is an
important principle here about the need
for ministers and
civil servants who often are handling
very sensitive material information
uh to have a safe space within which to
work
now uh you know i accept that cctv is a
factor of all our daily lives we're
probably being filmed
in all sorts of places as we go about
our lawful business
but i do think that there is a wider
issue here
uh of concern that we should all satisfy
ourselves about that there isn't
inappropriate
uh coverage being taken off sensitive
matters that could be used in a way by
those who wish us ill you know other
unfriendly governments or
or other people who uh do not have the
interests of our country at heart and
that's why i think jeremy's right to
debate these issues the specific case i
mean i i think it'd be
rather wrong would be to comment as to
whether it would have been
a breach of official secrets i i think
that um
really a general principle it has been
raised here
but that's not to say that suddenly you
know
we should minister should retreat into a
secret world i think that would be
inappropriate as well
for public figures and we're accountable
to the public
should the police be investigating
them
uh really this was a system that was a
close circuit television system
presumably used for security
purposes uh and we all i think are very
familiar with data protection
and the dangers of sharing information
without authorization
for purposes that are unconnected for
the gathering of that data all these
issues are
swirling about this morning and if the
police are
asked to investigate i'm sure they will
do you think they should
i'm sorry we just missed the top of your
answer there forgive me sir because uh
we had a problem with the sound did you
say they should investigate or they
shouldn't the police
no what i said is that uh if if they're
asked you then of course they
they they should uh but it'll be very
much subject to any complaints being
made
for them do you have a cctv in your
office
well i've asked that question um i don't
think so i've never seen any camera
facilities i know there's cctv in the
building for obvious security
reasons but i'm sure that many of my
colleagues will be asking the same
question and making sure
that the offices are swept just in case
there are
uh unauthorized devices in there that
could be a national security breach i
think that's the sensible thing to do
when did you ask i asked on friday
uh so i expect to have those answers
later today
okay so you don't know yet yeah i mean
it's almost unbelievable
that uh that cabinet ministers don't
have regular sweeps of their office
well look i i mean i think i think uh
all of us make a reasonable assumption
that uh where uh you know they're
working away and that we're in a secure
environment bearing in mind all the
safety measures that are taken in order
to protect our
buildings but hey you raised a really
legitimate question
um and i think frankly
sweet should be conducted regularly
particularly
where a sensitive material is being
handled i mean i don't know
about other departments i can think of
other departments where sensitive and
often secret material is handled
as a matter of course if that material
ever comes into my department we have a
special place
uh where that is viewed so i can assure
viewers that
we have very uh sophisticated and
sensible
security measures in place so that um
those documents don't fall into the
wrong hands and that they can't be seen
by people who are not authorized to do
so
as secretary of state for justice
speaking to the prime minister which i'm
sure you have done
he must be saying we need to do these
regular sweeps from now on given what we
saw on friday morning
well i think all of us individually as
tablet ministers
are asking the right questions uh and no
doubt we will get further advice
on this matter i'm certainly taking i
think the necessary
action but in any event i wanted to
reassure everybody that
uh you know i don't play fast and loose
with documents we're very careful in the
department about that
okay and i'm very mindful of the
sensitive nature of some of the material
that i have
very quickly just before i let you go
chief inspector probation says uh
unifying of the probation service um is
what you are are looking to push this
morning um
is it essentially fixing chris
grayling's mess
well look i think there were some good
aspects of the work that was done in the
last seven years there were some really
excellent uh organizations involved with
the supervision of offenders
but i think that bringing together the
service in the way that we've done this
morning with
200 million of investment we've got a
thousand new probation officers coming
online 1500 in the next year
really focuses the need to cut crime and
i look forward to seeing the work of
probation officers later this morning
who monitor offenders work with the
police
and are dedicated to uh stopping the
cycle of criminality that is so
depressingly familiar
to many of us and which of course
creates more victims of crime
i'm excited by the reforms that i've
steered through
and i look forward to successful times
ahead for our dedicated
probation officers okay justice
secretary i know you must flee
it's a pleasure to speak to you as i
said thank you for joining us thank you
thank you germany and france will today
push for an eu-wide two-week quarantine
for people
entering from countries of concern
including ours
it comes as portugal imposes a 14-day
isolation for british tourists who can't
prove that they are
fully vaccinated ryanair's chief exec
was on the program actually on friday
and he questioned why fully vaccinated
people faced any travel restrictions at
all
there should be no restrictions on those
people going to europe and
equally no restrictions on european
visitors coming to london in the uk
if they're fully vaccinated they're not
a risk they're not a threat
and i think it would also undermine mrs
merkel's
somewhat stupid idea this week that
somehow british
arrivals into germany should vaccinate
provide should isolate for five days
why well our europe correspondent adam
parsons joining us now from brussels
hello to adam they're starting to circle
the wagons against uk visitors aren't
they
i don't know if they're that obsessed
frankly with uk visitors the bottom line
is that the uk
is not in the eu it's not in the
schengen
movement area and countries like germany
and france particularly i think the
germans say look these are the rules
for the rest of the world the uk is no
great exception to that yes they have a
lot of tourists coming
uh into the eu but frankly if we're
going to have a set of rules we have to
apply them to
everybody and so they're saying uh
the the rules for the uk should be the
same as they were if you're coming from
america or china or
anywhere else and that will mean
quarantine now portugal
very popular tourist destination has
just put in uh
its own quarantine 14 days for people
who are not
fully vaccinated there is a significant
difference between those who are fully
vaccinated
and those who are not and the rest of
the eu's being encouraged to come into
line
behind that at the moment it's a bit
fragmented spain
greece malta cyprus all have
exemptions for uk tourists and one of
the reasons the germans are nervous is
that they
think that if people with the delta
variant or susceptible to that get into
the eu
they're then free to move around never
underestimate the nervousness there is
here
about the high rates of delta that they
see in the uk okay thank you
uh let me tell you about a number of
military top brass they are isolating
this morning
uh becky cottrell joining us from the
newsroom hi becky what happened
well this all centers around a meeting
with the head
of the armed forces general sir nick
carter and the defense secretary
and britain's most senior military
commanders last week on thursday
it was at the defence academy in
oxfordshire now a day later
general sonnet carter tested positive
for covert 19 it was
after attending a cultural festival in
wiltshire it was a routine
covid test and it meant that the
secretary of state and the heads of the
royal navy
the raf and strategic command were
contacted
by the nhs test and trace app and told
to isolate
for 10 days now although their meeting
with the chief of the defence staff is
classed as
close contact officials say that social
distancing protocols
were followed now military business will
be conducted
remotely for the next few days and that
will be disruptive not least because
there will be
highly classified sensitive information
that they are unlikely to discuss
via virtual platforms at home because
they won't be deemed secure enough
okay for now thank you thanks a lot
becky u.s navy has completed the first
scheduled event of
full ship shock trials on its newest
aircraft carrier the uss
gerald r ford wow can you imagine that
being so close to where you're actually
sitting in the middle of the sea what if
it didn't work properly
goodness live explosions live explosions
test the ability of the ship to deal
with battle conditions before
its full deployment thankfully
as you can see all went well
still to come on the program for you
security concerns in whitehall over how
that footage of matt hancock came to be
recorded and leaked to the press
we'll speak to an expert who used to
advise on the prime minister's safety
at half past seven scientists identify
more than
1500 star systems where aliens
could be looking back at earth we'll be
speaking to ufo investigator
malcolm robinson at 7 45
this matter is not closed labour calls
for a full-scale investigation into matt
hancock's conduct
in office after reports he used his
private email
to conduct government business we'll
speak to the party's deputy leader
angela rainer at
8 10.
now wimbledon gets underway today but
home fans have already suffered a blow
after british number one johanna conte
withdrew from the tournament after one
of her team tested positive
for kovid 19. how frustrating our sports
presenter jackie
baltrow is at the all england club for
us hello to jackie
good morning oh what a blow for her
yeah absolute blow for joe she's been
playing really well and she won a
tournament in nottingham
last week so she was all set for the
grass but you know the players know the
risks
um of playing in this environment
normally they would all stay in houses
around here that they would rent off
local people
but this time it's a very strict player
bubble they're all in the same hotel
in westminster and they're allowed to
take three people in with them so she'd
picked her fiance
and two support coaches so one of them
has obviously tested positive
and she has now got to go and
self-isolate for 10 days and luckily she
lives quite near that hotel so they've
allowed her
to go home but you know for the rest of
them
it's sort of like wimbledon as we know
it with a few
covered tweaks so uh when they go
through that gate behind me today there
will be
50 capacity everyone that turns up will
already have a ticket there's no queuing
they've already bought their ticket and
they have to go in
and show that they have a proof um with
a certificate of either a double
vaccination
proof of antibodies or a negative test
with a certificate so they've had to
jump through a few hoops just to go and
watch the players
as have the players who want to play in
it they will start with 50
capacity which is about 21 000 people
through the gates today and that will
rise they hope
as the tournament goes on because it's
part of a government
test event event to see what happens
when they get a lot of people
together and they're very much hoping
that by semi-finals and finals weekend
they will be at full capacity
for centre court which is 15 000. and
once you get into your seat
um even though you've got to wear a mask
when you're walking around the campus
when you sit down in your seat you can
take your mask off there isn't any
social distancing or if you go to any of
the restaurants
you don't have to wear a mask what they
weren't clear on
was if hammond hill is open they said it
would be
i don't know if they've done socially
distanced picnic blankets
or what they've done but it is open it
will be socially distant
it is wimbledon back after two years but
as i said with a few tweaks
okay jackie thank you we'll find out
what the weather's doing for wimbledon
in a short time but first police
currently looking for a spectator who
caused a crash
at this year's children france before
leaving the scene my goodness
uh that's what it looked like the woman
held a cardboard sign on the side of the
course which caused german rider tony
martin to lose control
leading to a subsequent pileup it
claimed legal proceedings planned to be
launched
against the suspect
i want to take you to miami now families
hoping for news of loved ones after an
apartment block collapsed
in miami have been asking authorities
whether a sinkhole was to blame
frustrations evident at a community
meeting nine people
are now known to have died in the
collapse more than 150
remain unaccounted for our u.s
correspondent martha kelner reports now
from
surfside area of miami where the
building was located
there's little solace to be found in a
tragedy like this
but in the temple british woman bhavna
patel calls her second home
there is at least togetherness
mother-in-law pratimo prays for a
miracle that
bhavna american husband vishal and
one-year-old aishani who were on the
third floor of the tower
will be found alive
bhavna is four months pregnant if the
collapse had been two days previously
she would have been here for a ritual
ceremony the lottery of circumstance is
agonizing
they're very more than family to me
their loved ones more than family
because they actually you know live in
this temple for a long time
i still cannot believe that they leave
us but
we just has to have a very strong bond
of the memory
families of the missing have been moved
to this hotel
they're receiving regular updates from
authorities but those briefings are
growing more
tense by the day as the desperation
intensifies
in one of these meetings a woman whose
sister is missing
asks why there aren't more answers for
her
was there a sinkhole under that first
building so i just want to know
ma'am i i we're the fire department
we're first responders we have no idea
that's the structural engineers that's
the building down there you mean to tell
me you can't tell what's original
parking lot and what may have came down
families were taken on a convoy of buses
to visit the collapse
site underneath this debris a trench has
been dug
125 feet long and 20 feet wide
to act as a fire break and allow better
access
rescue teams say though all power and
telecommunication
signals from the building are now gone i
realize this is a highly emotive issue
both for your men and women in the field
and also for the families
are you able to say when this search and
rescue effort
becomes a search and recovery operation
no at this time
i'm not hope and that's what i'm
focusing on
so i'm going to continue that as much as
possible that's the driving message
that's what we're looking for
it's a strange type of grief when there
is no certainty
this is one family's way of coping
across miami and beyond others are
forging their own way through the
heartache
martha kellner sky news florida
150 still missing as a result
of that building collapse in miami of
course we will monitor that throughout
the course of the day for you here on
sky news
um also watching for you today at first
day of wimbledon what's the weather
going to be like here's joe morning joe
good morning good morning to you well
unfortunately the south is not enjoying
the best of the weather at the moment
we've seen some really heavy rain
overnight
so if you are traveling to wimbledon or
anywhere at all
do be careful there's a lot of standing
water surface spray
and in fact tomorrow we'll have the same
issue with wembley
quite a few showers around but let's
take a look at the detail
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you well it's this
area of low pressure that is the culprit
really the rain just circulating round
and we've currently got some very wet
conditions across parts of west wales
and the southwest are warning out until
10 o'clock for that rain area and then
later on
we get a further warning for
thunderstorms
some with hail which will be working
their way into southern parts of the
country so again that could be a risk
for wimbledon this afternoon so really
we've got three areas of weather
up towards the north and the west this
is where we see the best of the weather
temperatures around 22 or 23 degrees
celsius
central areas looking rather gloomy with
outbreaks of rain on and off throughout
the day and it's cool
16 to 18 and then in the south brighter
with those thunderstorms
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now it might not look like a big crowd
but up to 2 000 people are thought to
have attended
an illegal rave in west sussex
[Music]
party was shut down and over 50 arrests
were made after police were called to
fields near the town of
stenning in the early hours of sunday
morning
under current coronavirus restrictions
gatherings may not exceed 30 people
without a legal exemption
now the justice secretary has said he's
asked for his office to be swept for any
unauthorized devices following the
leaked video of matt hancock kissing his
aide
gina colladangelo robert buckland said
if such a device
were found it could be a national
security breach
i think frankly sweet should be
conducted regularly particularly where a
sensitive material is being handled i
mean i don't know
about other departments i can think of
other departments where sensitive and
often secret material is handled
as a matter of course if that material
ever comes into my department we have a
special place
uh where that is viewed so i can assure
viewers that
we have very uh sophisticated and
sensible
security measures in place so that um
those documents don't fall into the
wrong hands and they can't be seen by
people who are not authorized to do so
well tamara is here so he said saw the
paper on
friday got his office swept absolutely
called up and said have i got a camera
in my office and clearly there are a lot
of unanswered questions
still about this whole affair about
ministers not knowing that there are
cameras in their offices who has access
to the
footage from those cameras we still
don't know how it was leaked there are
big questions
about that and the investigations to
come there are also big questions
as robert buckland conceded about matt
hancock's use of personal emails for
departmental business
about the conditions under which gina
collin d'angelo was employed was their
relationship
declared or was it going at the time
that she got that job back in
september there are matt hancock's
resignation
despite being over social distancing
guidelines ostensibly
doesn't shut down all these big
questions and of course we're going to
be hearing from the brand new health
secretary today
only his second day in the job for sajid
javid updating us
on when the covered restrictions will be
lifted i understand it's pretty unlikely
just because matt hancock's resigned
though doesn't mean that there aren't
any questions still left to answer as
far
as um his aide slash mistress is
concerned
absolutely um she was given a
taxpayer-funded job in september but has
been working for him it seems
unofficially
for at least a couple of years now and
as robert buckland said
if they were in a personal relationship
he should have declared it
and we don't know when that relationship
began so a lot of questions there and if
she was hired properly why did she give
up her post
at the weekend so yes i think there is a
lot more to come there and
none of that has been shut down and
we'll be hearing from labour later who
definitely don't want
these questions to be shut down indeed
so now thanks so much indeed also
hearing from
ed davey who is the leader of the
liberal democrats and
as we're hearing there from tomorrow um
angela rayner will be joining us
as well very shortly indeed before all
of that let's talk about security in
more detail professor michael clark
distinguished fellow at the royal united
services institute is with us hello to
professor thanks for joining us
on the program today what sort of
questions would you be asking
um i'd be asking the first questions of
the security company or the company that
services the dhss it's an american
listed company called
mcor and there's an encore uk who say on
their website that they've had a
contract since 2001
to provide lots of facilities to the
department of health including
waste management and catering
and security fabrics and so on
and they cover all aspects of security
including it would seem cctv
so the question is this particular
camera
appears to have been in place since
about 2017
so the first question is did they put
the camera there and if so
who knew about it and why was the camera
placed in a minister's office because as
somebody else has been saying it isn't
just to catch
uh illicit kisses that one might have a
camera in a minister's office there are
lots of documents
being put up put around left on tables
high definition cameras can
read documents as we've seen from people
coming in and out of downing street
so my first set of questions would be
the facilities company and i think you
can bet they're not saying anything at
the moment
but you can bet that whitehall officials
are descending on them
or have done in the last two or three
days with a fine-tooth comb
the other possibility is that the camera
isn't part of the m core contract and
was placed there illegally
and if that were the case then i think
you'd be looking at journalistic sources
probably
either way does um getting that
information
and giving it to a third party breach
the official secrets act in your opinion
uh it looks as if this doesn't at the
moment because this has been
a a camera capture and somebody has
seen it legally or really illegally
and passed it on as such it's hard to
say that what has been passed on
is a matter of national security and it
mi5
so far are saying that they may advise
the investigation but they're not now
part of it
and nor at the moment is the
metropolitan police but if it turns out
that this camera has captured
other things then it may well become a
matter of national security and
certainly
the government will be very concerned as
with most of the cabinet
at the idea that there are cameras in
their offices um i think most cabinet
ministers should assume
that they're being watched all the time
every day but they must
also want to assume that their offices
are swept
and are private and are places where
they can do business
without fear of being watched but if
there's a camera on the ceiling
you can see it can't you generally uh
not necessarily this one was inside a
fire alarm or a smoke alarm allegedly
we don't know that allegedly allegedly
as
you can know as you know from your own
computers a camera aperture can be very
very small just a little dot
and if it's if it's part of a six other
dots
uh if it's the third one along in a row
of six how would you necessarily spot it
um cameras can be hidden very very
efficiently
um whatever the reason the fact that it
has been copied and given to a third
party
does that mean a criminal investigation
should be has the law been broken
uh that at the moment that's not clear
um that may turn out to be the case just
on grounds of privacy
um but i think that's a question
probably for the end of the week
when people discover who owns this
camera
and who uh or what sort of people will
have
will have transferred the footage or
given the footage to the newspaper
as i say it doesn't sound like a
national security issue at the moment
but it may turn out to be a privacy
issue certainly
what about using private email addresses
for government business how vulnerable
does that make
a minister very uh
they shouldn't do it they all do it or a
lot of them do it the americans do it
it's very it's very tempting for a
minister who is otherwise
uh completely overseen by the civil
service and everything has to go on
record
it's very tempting particularly in a
crisis or under pressure
to want to deal with your friends or
people that you trust
um privately um when mobile phones first
came out and not many people have them
like i know of at least
two ministers who sat in their office
with their mobile phone like a house
brick
on the desk so they could speak to their
private advisors without the civil
service necessarily
listening in there's always a temptation
to do it and they shouldn't
and normally it's not a problem but when
it becomes a problem
it makes the minister look very foolish
and very insecure
do you think that's how matt hancock
looks this morning
i'm afraid that the whole series of
things this like so many issues
they they unravel step by step so
the the the case the extra marital
affair then
as it were exposes the fact that he was
not very secure in the way that he
uh conducted his communications then it
goes back on contracts that he may have
given without
uh due process the whole thing goes goes
step by step by step
and none of it is good for his
reputation nor for the reputation of the
government
which is already being made to look by
the opposition
like a pretty careless government that
really doesn't think about the
procedures doesn't really stick to the
rules doesn't see why it should
well i remember labour losing a couple
of cds with uh i think
many many hundreds of thousands of
pieces of information private
information
uh from people and i think that was from
the foreign office wasn't it at the time
or was it from the
treasury yeah it happens with depressing
regularity
and um in these days there is so much
information in circulation on so many
different platforms
that it will tend to happen but that's a
reason for
ministers and government to be even more
tight than they were 10 and 20 years ago
not about as tight as they were these
things will continue to happen but they
are damaging
and we hope that this one is only a
matter of as it were private
embarrassment it doesn't go any further
into the national fabric but i fear that
when we find out more about this
surveillance issue it may turn out
that there's a great deal more things
leaking than we would than we thought
would be
acceptable okay professor good to talk
to you thanks for your expertise
appreciate it
looking at how this morning's newspapers
are covering the story
for you today let's start with the metro
should we hancock clinch is reported to
police
the headline in the metro as bereaved
families call for him to be prosecuted
for his breach of covid rules
the mirror not holding back disgusting
the headline there
pm still has big questions to answer
over hancock
says the guardian and in the eye
calling to review security across
whitehall
after the leaked video of matt hancock
embracing his aid
uh let's uh return to the former health
secretary's um
constituency how has this affair gone
down
with voters they're joined now by the
editor
of the east anglian daily times and
ipswich star and that's brad jones hello
to brad
it's great to see you this morning
always fabulous to talk to a fellow
journalist
um talk to me about how this resignation
and affair has played out in the
constituency
morning well we we can only go by the
people we've spoken to
the response we've had from our suffolk
readers
um to our coverage of the story over the
last three days
and it is overwhelmingly that matt
hancock's position was
completely untenable now when this story
broke on friday
uh the majority of the people we spoke
to
in the constituency said he should
either resign or be sacked
and initially at least that clearly
didn't happen and that and and
people felt that way for all the reasons
we've now all heard they
they felt he had displayed complete
hypocrisy
by breaking the very rules that he had
asked everybody else to follow for the
last 15 months
but then over the weekend we saw readers
increasingly
question why mr hancock wasn't sacked by
the prime minister
and that's actually what we've said in
our leader column today that we believe
that's what the pm should have done
the public wants honesty integrity and
competency from politicians
as a minimum and too often we're not
we're not getting that
and um the other thing we noticed over
the weekend was there was
in in the constituency there was not a
sense of
local supporters rushing to stand up for
matt hancock
we tried to speak to lots of other
senior
conservatives in the county but very
very few were actually picking up the
phone
one who did was uh waveney mp peter
alders fellow conservative
and he said that he felt that um matt
hancock was right to resign agreed his
position had become untenable
and said he'd received lots of emails
from upset constituents
so that that kind of gives a feeling for
for
for how it's how it's played out here um
there was also quite a lot of
speculation yesterday about
um the local constituency party and
um as a suggestion they were so angry
about
what had happened with matt hancock that
he may even be facing
de-selection at the next election now
again three days three days on
uh west suffolk conservatives are still
to make any official comment on this
story
we did speak to the deputy chairman very
very briefly yesterday and he says he
didn't know where that line had come
from
but we don't know their official
positions so
um that maybe they're still waiting to
see how this this plays out in the next
few days because
as as you said earlier there are still
many questions to be answered
do your readers give you the impression
that
their mp has got a future in politics
though or not
it's really hard to say at the moment i
mean matt hancock
is he's in a really safe tory seat he's
i mean since he was elected in 2010 he's
increased his
his share of the vote every single
election
some of the people we spoke to yesterday
said that this
this is going to put a lot of people off
voting for him
um and i expect it will uh
it's going to be really interesting to
see how the public reacts
this in his constituency over the the
kind of mid to long term
if you know that assuming that west
suffolk conservatives do
stand by him okay it's good to talk to
you uh keep in touch thanks very much
thanks thanks a lot uh we are hoping to
take you to
uh sydney shortly where uh sydney and
that is that what people are called
sydney cider sydney people from sydney
anyway
sydney siders there we go um are waking
up to another lockdown
of two weeks tell you about that very
shortly indeed but first scientists have
identified
1715 star systems
they've counted them where aliens could
have discovered earth by observing our
planet's
transit the research published in the
journal nature found that 75 of those
stars came close enough to listen
in to our radio broadcasts hopefully
they were watching sky
joined now by scottish ufo investigator
and paranormal researcher
malcolm robinson hello to you it's great
to see you again
um 1 715 star systems where aliens
might be 29 planets picking up our radio
broadcasts
do we run and hide
well like i said before planet earth is
about a tiny grain of sand on a huge
cosmic beach
and it's incomprehensible to think we
stand alone in the vastness of the
cosmos
we've been sending out radio and
television signals since the the dawn of
time will
effectively you know since since the
invention of these devices one of which
was of course
invented by a scotsman at john logan
beard
but it's like a party gate it's like a
party the noise
is coming out of a house and we have who
we have invited
in our house but hearing the noise of
this party
are uninvited visitors gate crashers if
you like
so the insinuation here is that we have
to be very very careful
who we let into our house and our house
being planet earth
and when we remember that um orson
welles novel
war of the worlds came out in 1838
and h.g wells's play came out in 1938
now when that came out and went across
many parts of america
many people who tuned in late thought it
was a real deal
you know i thought it was a real
something real happening in planet earth
and there was
chaos absolute chaos throughout parts of
america
indeed some people even committed
suicide so
we have to be very very careful about
what we are sending out and what we get
back
no one would have believed uh if you
know you know
um will we know in our lifetimes whether
there are aliens
well i would like to think so i mean
there's no denying as i said in a
previous program with uk
that we are seeing many craft in our
skies which are beyond
explanation they defy gravity they defy
physics etc they've been seen over
missile silos they've been reported by
military pilots
etc so we do have something substantial
and flying in the skies of this planet
will it be
answered in our lifetime well i'd like
to think so
i mean you're looking at some footage
from the uss
nimitz which was short of a strange
object flying in the sky
uh back in 2004 very unusual objects
these defy
explanation at this moment in time but
there's no denying k
absolutely no denying that we have a ufo
presence here on planet earth
now it's great that the scientists have
found these 29 planets which allegedly
can pick up a radio broadcast or tv
broadcast
but it's like i said before you know we
have to be very careful
who we are inviting into our house um
you know would it change religion do we
have one god or do we have a plethora
of gods out there we are sending our own
probes out to mars the mars rover etc
maybe what we see in the skies are
probes from other planets
it's all debatable you know people have
their own ideas as to what's going on
right now
but it's fantastic that the scientists
have
confirmed that they are indeed habitable
planets of a description
out there that may be receiving our
signals but it
is a life form like ours you know it
depends on the planet
i mean here on planet earth we have our
satellite moon if that was further away
planet earth would probably not survive
we have the sun to give us warmth warmth
etc
so any habitable planet out there in the
vastness of the cosmos would need
to have those same conditions the
satellite moon and a star
to make life evolve it might be
microscopic life out there
but one thing's for sure i don't think
we stand alone
in the vastness of the cosmos as well or
could it be like your nessie key ring up
there on the bookshelf and a complete
myth
well who knows you know i mean nessie i
love nessa i've been up
at the loch ness many times i've been
very fortunate to have went down in a
submarine in loch ness looking for
nessie back in 1994.
um nessie's an entirely different
subject but i do believe but
we have something very real very large
and stone art is the best evidence to
suggest
we have nessie and loch ness fantastic
great to talk to you again come back and
speak to us soon thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you
so 29 planets can pick up radio
broadcasts and tv broadcasts
from the earth very good morning to you
whichever planet you're watching from
today let's take you to sydney uh waking
up uh
in another lockdown today
now whilst uh the numbers today are less
than the numbers yesterday we have to be
prepared
for the numbers to bounce around and we
also have to be prepared for the numbers
to go up considerably because
as experience shows with this strain we
are seeing
almost 100 of transmission within
households
and we're seeing a very high rate of
transmissibility
pretty alien news for lots of aussies
this morning
sky news australia reporter charlotte
mortlock joining us from
sydney not what people wanted to hear is
it good morning
now certainly not what sydney signers
were hoping for certainly
considering how well we did last year
throughout this pandemic you can see
right now i'm at the iconic sydney opera
house and it is very eerie there's
hardly anyone around the cbd and that's
because we are
in lockdown that was initiated on
fridays we've been about three days
through and it is set to end
in 14 days we are very hopeful that will
be the case today was good news we saw
18 new cases that is down from
yesterday's
30. so fingers crossed we do see that
downwards trend continuing but our
authorities
are saying that because this delta
strain is so strong and so
transmissible we're seeing around 100 of
the household contacts
becoming infected that's up from 30
percent and what we have seen on
previous strains so
over the next few days we will start to
see the infected people transmitting
that to their household contacts and
then we'll get a better gauge
on if we are likely to come out of this
lockdown on the 9th
of july certainly it has been a real
uh i guess roller coaster here in
australia because we did so well last
year with a very
small amount of deaths in comparison to
what we have seen overseas
but this year we are seeing a lot of
frustration from australian residents
over the slow
vaccine rollout in new south wales the
premier gladys barrett jeclean says that
we will be able to avoid potentially
going into lockdowns and having
restrictions when they're outbreaks when
we see 80
of the adult population vaccinated now
the magic number we're aiming for there
is
10 million vaccinations at this stage
we're at 2 million so we do have quite a
bit of a way to go
okay good to talk to you thank you keep
well thank you
first day of wimbledon today which could
only mean one thing
can't it joe
yeah probably lots of rain and in fact
we've got some very wet conditions for
southern parts of the country
not just today we've had wet weather
over the weekend and it's not looking to
improve too quickly this week either
meanwhile the far north and west are
having a lovely time let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you well over the
weekend we've seen this area of low
pressure develop
and that's been churning rain around and
we've got some very heavy rain this
morning
over parts of wales and the southwest
and we've seen lots of wet weather
overnight as well so pretty unpleasant
driving conditions
a lot of surface water standing uh water
and surface spray
and we'll continue to see that through
the course of the day as this area of
rain starts to edge its way northwards
as things brighten up in the far south
we'll find
temperatures rising and and as that
happens we'll see
a lot of heavy thundery showers
developing as well along southern most
coast so
further wet weather to come top
temperatures probably around 23 24
degrees celsius the better weather is
over parts of scotland
parts of ireland as well as we go
through this evening and overnight
turning chilly here
staying rather gloomy through central
parks and further heavy rain to come
down in the south